[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 145 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
hi I'm mark Randall and as always i'm
here with my colleague melanie work
how you doing melanie i'm good mark good
to talk to you again this week
how was pax pax was great pax was
wonderful pax dev was lovely pax itself
was great got to catch it with loads of
friends it was really good all the
gaming things last week everything last
week was a busy week there was go freak
on there was burning man's it was a
pretty busy week and then long weekend
yeah which was good this week we are
going to be speaking with dr. Mario last
nick who is out of CERN he's joined us
on the podcast at one of our wonderful
recordings that we were able to capture
it next and he joined us to talk to us
about Atlas and how Atlas is using GCP
so we're gonna have that as our
interview for this week yeah really
exciting stuff thank you for setting
that up Melanie yeah I'm glad we were
able to connect with them but as always
we will start off with our cool things a
week and this week's question is I'm not
familiar with docker or kubernetes how
can I get started with them how can you
get started you know we were having a
good conversation about how sometimes
it's good to revisit you know where to
go how to get started with some of these
topics because a lot of people are still
new coming into the space foundational
stuff is always important very much so
cool so when we get stuck into our cool
things of the week it wouldn't be an
episode of the podcast if I didn't talk
about kubernetes so why don't we do that
a couple of topics on that one which I
thought were really cool kubernetes
released a blog post recently talking
about how they use machines basically to
do or they're testing your CI to
automate the contributor experience I
think this is really cool if you've ever
been involved with a kubernetes project
or even any open source project you can
tell that pull requests and continuous
integration and anything like that can
get really complicated and kubernetes is
a big project so they go through all the
different projects that they've either
written or used just to basically manage
this I don't know an artistic duo cracy
of open-source that makes things happen
which is pretty exciting the good follow
up from that though is that up until
recently all this infrastructure has
been run by Google cloud but what we
want to do is hand that over to the
cloud native
compute foundation so that's actually
happened and what we've also done is
provided nine million dollars and
credits to allow that infrastructure to
run on Google cloud so it's going back
over to
the foundation which is really good I
mean criminal DS is obviously a mature
open-source project so they should have
ownership of that kind of stuff so I'm
pretty excited to see what that's going
to continue doing yeah it looks like
they're using nine million in credits
for over three years
part of that grant will be dedicated to
funding scalability testing with regular
runs unlike one hundred fifty thousand
containers across five thousand virtual
machines efforts like that better are
very much needed in this space but yes
this is a good move in regards to
helping to make the scene cf more
capable of supporting the larger
community mm-hmm so another thing we
wanted to mention in terms of cool
things of the week is that the product
that we provide called cloud talent
solution helps with job search as well
as for recruiters to be able to find
talent there's been an additional
functionality that was added to it for
veterans who are transitioning out of
military service into civilian life and
are looking for jobs it helps translate
their terminology and what they're used
to from a military perspective into a
civilian resume skill set perspective
without them having to do it themselves
so they don't have to think about what
those words need to be from a civilian
side of the world they can just put in
their actual terminology that they use
regularly and the product itself will do
the translation for them and help them
surface jobs that they're looking for in
the civilian market yeah this looks like
really impressive it's being used
currently across FedEx and compass
health Siemens as well as through
powering veteran job sites like getting
hired and other job boards like
Careerbuilder and Mid America Korea's so
I'm really happy to see this initiative
agreed and then another cool thing of
the week that we want to mention is John
Faust who's one of our team members has
posted his first blog and it's
specifically on unity for beginners from
a beginner and I know mark we did that
great podcast not too long ago on unity
so you've got a lot of knowledge in this
space and it was good to see John
participate and share what his
experience has been yeah it's really
good he goes through several different
game engines why he particularly chose
unity over the other ones and this sort
of gave a bit of a general overview as
well and he's going to continue the
series I think this is one of just a
beginning it is it's a nice assessment
and then sort of the next steps of what
that's going to look like last cool
thing of the week that we want to
mention is that for many of you who are
researchers in the AI and machine
learning space you are aware of the
neural information processing systems
conference also known as
nips this conference is something that
is regularly attended by those
researchers and others in the community
and it always happens in December and
we're actually going to do a podcast
about that later this year something to
note is that the registration for that
finally opened this week and within what
I understand about 15 minutes of it
opening it sold out which is her new
record for them last year it sold out in
two days so it's one of the more
established conferences and well
attended from the community's
perspective so it's impressive that it
sold out but maybe not that surprising
as quickly as it did something I wanted
to give a shout out though to it is that
they're providing child care all of
which I think is wonderful and I know
they did that at ICML which is another
regularly attended conference so anyways
if you wanted to go to this conference
you want to learn more about it you know
there's great information online there's
a lot of information around the papers
that are going to be there in regards to
registration if you wanted to attend my
understanding is they may be releasing
more tickets later on in the fall and
you can always put yourself on the
waitlist AI so hot right now it is all
the things right now anyways mark I
think it's time for us to go speak with
dr. Mario last night on this week's
podcast we're excited that we have dr.
Mario last nick who has joined us from
cern and specifically the atlas project
over at cern and we're recording this
podcast out of next as we speak so you
might hear some fun ambient noise in the
background but yes mario thank you so
much for joining well I'm excited to be
here thanks for having me great can you
tell us a little bit about who you are
and what you do over at CERN I've joined
Cernan roughly 12 years ago as a PhD
student Beckman I'm a software engineer
and I've been working on the data
management part of the Atlas experiment
and right now I'm kind of coordinating
the whole data management activity for
the experiment which means the
management of the namespace access to
the files transferring orchestrated
activities with the team of roughly 10
to 15 persons distributed from
Institute's in the United States like
Stanford
laboratory Brookhaven National Lab
Rutherford Appleton Laboratory in the UK
also people at CERN and then from some
other Institute's that contribute a lot
so for those people who aren't familiar
with CERN and what CERN does can you
give us like a high level like what is
sarin do you sirness of particle physics
laboratory it was founded in 1954 if I'm
not mistaken something are there yeah
the building's look like that yeah I can
tell you so what we have is a
accelerator complex where we try to
figure out what the Constituent
processes are that make up our universe
it's kind of like where astronomy looks
back in the history of time we drilled
down like a microscope it's kind of two
aspects of the same thing so we have
four experiments four large experiments
attached at the Large Hadron Collider
and one of them is Atlas that's where
I'm working on can you tell us a little
bit more about what Atlas is so Atlas is
a general-purpose particle detector you
have to imagine that the seller ATAR
people are making sure that the protons
collide in the center of the detector
and then you have two decaying particles
going through all the layers of the
detector we get hits in the detector
those are read out by the electronics
and then we try to figure out from these
hits what the decaying particles
actually were so they deposit energy in
the detector invariant mass those kinds
of things so what kind of technology do
you need through this like what do you
do with this stuff
the actual technologies are custom-built
so those are built upon the experiences
from the previous detectors that came so
the original particle detectors were
completely analog and now we move to a
more digital way of reading out these
electronics you have to imagine the the
readout from all the electronics on the
detector is roughly for not mistaken 1.5
petabytes per second and then this is
then triggered down in hardware and
later on through software and then we
get event sizes roughly two to eight
megabytes in size depending on what's
going on its proton or light events so
my understanding is you're using some of
the GCP products with the data that
you're managing what are some of the
products that you're using
we completely integrated the Google
Cloud storage and the Google compute
engine and the one thing that's always
missing in this picture is that we also
have use of the G suite that's great
because it's really it's a collaborative
effort and by making sure that everybody
has access to all the documents slides
and everything this is a wellness part
in the whole thing
so you said there was 400 petabytes of
data per second is that all going into
like Google Cloud Storage no we couldn't
for that 400 petabytes of data is what
we have in total guide and from the
detector roughly 20 percent of that is
detected data the rest is simulated data
so you have theoretical physicists
coming up with formulas to go to the
experimental physicists they make
physics simulations and then we try to
figure out from the simulated data we
compare it with the real data from the
detector to
if we have any excess in the histograms
to see if particular property works out
or not
Thanks so in terms of Google Cloud
storage in particular how are you using
that so we have our internal data
management system that is basically
tailored to the way we have our
computing infrastructure built we have
170 data centers those are all
nationally funded data centers so it's
completely heterogeneous so our system
was built to make sure that all these
data centers can talk to each other and
now we added the Google cloud platform
as an extension to that so for the whole
infrastructure it looks like that the
Google source is just another data
center for us and we started out with
with the s3 compatibility layer of
cheese yes but then gradually due to
authorization we moved to assign your
else and now we can use it just like a
regular web dev storage which is pretty
cool that is super cool are you just
using it for storage
are you computing stephanas well I think
you said you're using GCE yes so from
the workflow management point of view
we're operating on a slightly different
scale so we have fewer users we have
roughly have 2000 users but if one user
pushes a button and launches a job that
job potentially has to work through 50
60 petabytes of data and there's all
split up into smaller sub jobs across
all these data centers and especially
before physics conferences you have
contention so they would try to get
their histogram stand for their papers
and that is where we then spill over
compute to GCE so we can fire up VMs on
cheesy ship the data that is needed from
our internal data centers into GCS do
the computation and then shut it down
when we're done nice and you're using
kubernetes too as well yes so the
certain data center is kubernetes
enabled now and in fact one of the
things I saw it next now that was
announced was the kubernetes on-premise
getting in touch with you a lot of
people are excited about that what
specifically are you excited about in
regards to that for you from the
application point of view this means
that we can scale out on a much easier
level because procurement is very much
hardwired and so we we have to make you
a resource request like that but if we
can say we scale out when we need it
then this gives us much more flexibility
when you were making decisions on the
tools to use what were some of the
reasons for why you decided on GCP or
the products you specifically chose for
us the the most important part was the
openness and the flexibility that we get
from that when we try to do this
internally we came up with our own
homegrown solutions and then suddenly
you start to have this second-order
effect which means you don't have any
developers coming in you into the
collaboration or leaving the
collaboration that actually know how to
operate this but when you focus on tools
that are basically industry standard you
open up your development and engineering
pool to a lot of people who can help you
out and this is very much understated
problem that we can solve with them so
from the technology itself it's it's
straightforward for us that's nice
and when you built this integrated
solution is it like do your scientists
need to know that they're running on gzp
or they're running on your data center
yeah we actually don't want them to know
for the user what they do is to make
selections on physics properties so
eventually they say give me this region
with this and that property and then it
comes out okay you need to run across
this one million files they're all over
the place and then you end up with a
selection of these files on contended
data centers and then we just take that
part ship it to GCS and to the
computation in TCP Thanks any lessons
learned along the way from building out
these tools so the most important thing
for me personally was to handle the
authority because the scientists are all
integrated in a has the US Europe Asia
in a single unified federated
authorization namespace and to get the
credentials from a single scientists
into the controlled budgeted environment
on the Google cloud platform there was a
bit tricky to figure out so we're happy
with that for example when we were still
using the s3 layer we had to give out
the s3 access keys to the people and
suddenly there could be a single
scientist saying okay I need to run the
stator and by accident starts to run on
cheesy and suddenly you rack up a bill
of things that you can't pay so that was
one of the reasons we had to really make
sure that the authorization under
funding
you're adding through yourself that then
we have a authorization layer built into
our data management system resume okay
in terms of the research that you're
doing with Atlas how is that research
used by the broader community so we've
always tried to build our data
management products on top of the
computer science literature so it's not
like we went ahead and just did
something radically different and this
also shows because we managed to get
quite a lot of PhDs out of it with
master students working that we're
regularly publishing papers just on the
way we do our data management and this
is much appreciated in the community on
the other hand is not only about
researchers source of making the product
generally available so if you go to get
up you can grab a copy of Ruscio and try
it out for yourself if you have it isn't
it ok and any specific groups that you
collaborate with that you'd be able to
share I know you you collaborate with a
lot of groups but some that come to mind
so from the universities we work with
very closely is the University of Oslo
in Norway poopit are in Germany and in
Spokane Austria and then from the larger
research laboratories it's mostly
Brookhaven National Lab in New York and
the University of Texas at Arlington ok
great
I'd love to hear more about the github
side of things how open is this data or
how open is this process is there stuff
that people can play with or yeah so we
even though this is essentially
principally CERN led project we have a
completely open apache license product
so you can just go there if you want to
try it out you grab the doctor images if
you find something that you want to fix
or you want to improve just file a
ticket on github either throught the
developers or do it yourself just
submitting and is this for general just
data processing or is it specific for
like CERN datasets yeah I'm guessing
people don't have access to certain
statuses so this is really the software
itself and if you have a data management
problem this is most likely a useful
solution for you if you want to get
access to the
experiment 8 itself you have to be a
member of the collaboration because what
we don't want is that people start to
get access to intermediary data and
suddenly you get an excited journalist
proclaiming some discovery that was not
confirmed by the collaboration so we
have to be very careful also with data
privacy become a member you have to join
an institute that is collaboration
member makes sense well what are some of
the future plans you have for
development of your platform so our
platform is currently being evaluated by
a couple of experiments namely the
Square Kilometre Array so that's a
really big radio astronomy project the
deep underground neutrino experiment
tuned at Fermilab LIGO is also
evaluating and a couple of other
high-energy particle physics experiments
CMS so what we are trying to do is we
are trying to branch out essentially
from Atlas into all these communities
we're trying to offer them a service a
product and support community where
everybody can contribute this means now
we have to make sure that the product
itself can tie into all the intricacies
and problems that these communities have
and try to solve them you know in a
generic way the way the system is built
is very modular so it's really not
specific to Atlas itself so that's why
we had very good success in the early
evaluation stages with the other
experiments that's great really happy
about there are other teams inside CERN
also using the same platform it's
essentially a single instance that hosts
the whole thing the whole thing yeah
what are the quirks of the science
community with regards to their data
when compared to a regular business
enterprise they start to get very
cautious when you mention the word
commercial platform because for a
scientist the data is if they don't have
full control over their data they start
to get very very anxious so it was our
job to ensure that when they want to
process data when they
to store data to ensure that even if
it's moved to commercial platform that
their data is secure but also that they
still retain full ownership and control
of the data it's more of a sociological
than a technological problem but you
have to make sure that you break this
mindset a bit and tell me you can trust
us the technology is secure and we're
therefore the scientists and not for the
commercial company that's our mantra I
know we're doing this interview at next
and you were here to speak it next what
did you talk about yeah exactly about
about this topic
yeah it was a shared session a
scientific computing with Google cloud
platform the first half was from the
Pangaea project did earth and ocean and
Atmospheric Sciences modeling on
interactive notebooks and then the
second half I spoke about the way we
integrated TCP into our Atlas computing
infrastructure cool where's the
interactive notebooks Jupiter by any
chance yes thanks yeah we did a podcast
on the project Jupiter oh yeah he took
122 anyways any exciting things that
you've seen it next while you've been
here outside of the arm Prem yeah I've
been speaking to a lot of people so in
fact I've actually spent most of my time
talking to people personally getting in
touch with the network people because
one of the things it's very important
for us is to get the data as quickly as
possible from our data centers into GCS
which meant we have to jump from the
national research and education networks
through the peering points into the
Google Network Wow
if we do that actually we can saturate
our data center output Oh fun
actually that's an interesting point to
you here with Google cloud platform as
well yes there are a couple of peering
points in the US and the ones we tried
out was if I'm not mistaken South
Carolina and Bruce Lee for those people
who may not know what peering is can you
talk a little about that it's
essentially a private network that is
directly connected to the Google
now that makes a lot of sense given the
amount of data that you're shifting
around now we don't want to get limited
by public networks so if we get through
boots that are 150 megabytes per second
we're gonna wait a long time that's cool
and understandable like you said well
great anything else that you wanted to
share with us before we let you go there
will be a Ruscio community workshop
sometime in autumn we still have to
define the time and place we had a
pretty successful one in March this year
okay but due to the uptake of the
community we thought maybe we'll make a
second one and now we will invite again
all the developers from the other
experiments will open it up even more
we're trying to branch out of our a
single experiment installation and try
to get even more people on board are you
actively looking for contributors and
people to get involved yes cool where
can they go if they want to get involved
github.com slash froz ok well great well
Mario thank you so much for joining us
today it was my pleasure
thank you Thanks thank you again Mario
we really appreciate you coming on to
the podcast and talking to us about
Atlas yes super cool super cool stuff so
mark I'm not familiar with docker
kubernetes where can I start to learn
about them yeah I'm just gonna I want to
talk about this a little bit more too
because I think as people who work in
technology we have a tendency to want to
talk about the new shiny thing all the
time
sometimes I think it's actually very
important to go back to the foundational
aspects of what we're building on top of
because sometimes people haven't got to
the new shiny things yet and that's
totally fair enough so if people are
like oh darker ink ribbon ADIZ maybe
this seems really complicated or where
do I get started the ecosystem has grown
so much I don't know where to go I just
wanted to provide some guidance and some
resources that are available so if
you're thinking about getting involved
are concrete manatees we definitely say
get started feeling comfortable with
docker
so there is Dockers official getting
started guide on their website which
will link to in the show notes which is
great gives you great step-by-step
instructions on how to get started
building containers pushing things to
registries that kind of stuff just
getting familiar with that vocabulary
and that tool chain I think it's a
really great start there's a website as
well called quatre coda they also have a
free interactive docker course that I
also really liked so if you don't want
to install any tools or just want to
just try it in the browser basically
they have a series of all kinds of stuff
they have oh wow there's there's a lot
there's I wanna say
least about 15 different things just
there waiting for you to play with it's
nice that it's inside the browser - yeah
if you if you're like okay cool I'm
feeling more comfortable with docker I
want to get started with kubernetes my
favorite place honestly to start is
there's a comic from the gke team
I think he's both amazing gorgeous and
just hilarious you are a fan of that
comic I love this coming yeah so well
done yeah and I think the wonderful
thing is is you can read the comic and
give you some ideas of the reasons and
like the basic like philosophies behind
kubernetes and then it just runs
straight into an interactive tutorial
that you can just pick up and run with
which i think is great too
and speaking of interactive tutorials
also one of my favorite sites cata coda
has a free interactive kubernetes course
as well which is just another lovely
place to get started so it's got stuff
in there even around like launching
clusters if that's something you might
want to do but even just things like
just starting to deploy containers doing
simple web apps just getting started
with really simple stuff - just to get
going and even so the more complicated
things as well so it's a really nice way
of getting going and just you know again
nice safe environment it's online it's
in a browser you don't have to install
anything or do anything special that way
either
when you start it out on this what were
some of the resources that you used
that's a really good question so I
started three years ago before
kubernetes was 1.0 this was a very
different landscape yeah so I kind of
grew up with the project so I have
certain like history so people who are
new to it I feel like things like this I
think are really good because I had a
very different upbringing in the in this
in this ecosystem lowers the barriers a
little bit on the resources that you're
recommending yeah cool mark where you
gonna be
where you going this month where am I
going this month where anteye going this
month when we talked about already I
think we've talked about it but just as
a reminder I'll be at Tokyo next next
week basically so pretty excited about
that gonna be doing the inside event
which is the game event they're talking
about that and then both of us will also
be it's strange loop shortly thereafter
as well agreed and you're speaking it
Tokyo next is that right yeah I'm doing
the inside event which is the game
specific event so I'll be speaking at
that and I'll be hanging around as well
yeah a couple of things yeah what are
you doing you're traveling - I am
traveling I'm going to be in South
Africa near Cape Town at deep-learning
in Java the conference that is
specifically machine-learning focus deep
learning focused in that area we're
going to be talking to a number
who are gonna be at the conference and
will be including some of that on the
podcast fantastic well I'm looking
forward to hearing that content me too
excellent well Melanie thank you for
joining me yet again on the podcast
Thank You Marc thank you all for
listening and we'll see you all next
week
[Music]